what's up guys I'm David and today I'm
doing wires on a complete interview and
by the way this isn't a wall I thought I
was gonna be a wall it's just a piece of
paper your people know that okay all
right what is david dobrik real name
that's my real name
David Dover except my middle name is
Julian but I don't talk I don't talk
about that that much cut that part out
what is david dobrik known for I hope no
he makes YouTube videos and he started
on vine and he's known for a really good
food reviews on Instagram that's what
I'm known for
what does david dobrik email it's david
dobrik and at oh you know what is it's
don't break D at aol.com and I haven't
used it in a while but send me some
stuff what is david dobrik montage song
like if I had one about my life it'd
probably feel it's still by Portugal a
man I really like that song what is
david dobrik zodiac sign I'm a Leo and
I'm on the cusp of it I was almost a
cancer Brahma Leo is david dobrik an
actor no no no no no no and he never
will be I couldn't even recite the
beginning line to this thing I'm doing
the interview that's how horrible I met
lines is david dobrik rich no he's
losing all his money really quickly I'm
rich in positive thoughts I'm super
positive is david dobrik dead no I mean
maybe to a lot of people he's definitely
bad but I'm very much alive for now is
david dobrik from slovakia yeah yeah
dobrik coming to australia no I'm not
I'm actually I'm not leave the country
because I am under what you would call
Decca so I can't leave the country
because then if I leave I can't reenter
for another ten years
fun fact does david dobrik have a house
I do have a house it's considered a
high-risk property because it's like
it's it's it's falling off the hill like
it's starting to crack so soon I won't
have a house does david dobrik have
siblings I have three Esther Sarah and
Toby I don't see him up quite often so I
think me saying their names and this is
in
for me not to see him for another couple
months I miss you guys does david dobrik
speak Spanish I took Spanish in high
school so no I know how to like get to
the bathroom and I know how to like get
to the library the only places i knows
biblioteca and el baño you don't know
where the library is
I'll ask does david dobrik have a test
like yes I do
and it's my favorite does david dobrik
speak Slovak yes I do I don't think I'm
gonna say anything no because I'm shy
what did david dobrik win at the
streamys i won
i'm something for ensemble and then i
won another one there I forgot first
person first person that's why my
assistants here Natalie tells me what I
want what is david dobrik birthday July
23rd 96 this was a little small one what
is david dobrik scar people are more
into my car than they are me which is
okay because I think I am too what is
david dobrik camera what is their word
over camera it's a Canon a TD I've had
it for a long time I think I've gone
through like six or seven of those
cameras are the best
what color are david dobrik eyes I don't
like that
who is david dobrik celebrity crush it's
ariana grande but I liked her when she
was on our victorious now everyone likes
her it's not it's just not fair who is
david dobrik his best friend of a bunch
of Ilya I have Liza I have Alex I have
the other Alex I don't like to make one
of them the best best friend because
then the others get mad at me but it's
so important to him my best friend who
is david dobrik related to um my
grandparents I don't I'm not related
anybody cool
my grandpa designed a fountain in
Slovakia
when is david dobrik going on tour
hopefully never again because the first
time david dobrik did a david dobrik
didn't like it
tours rough and it's a lot of work and
you get sick all the time everyone in
here is like he goes on tour i do a
podcast tour and it feels weird so all
we do is sit on stage and talk when did
David
Rick meet Jonah Jonah is my friend we
call him Jonah cuz he looks like Jonah
Hill his real name is Nick his family
doesn't even call him and Nick anymore
they all call him Jonah he came to my
apartment like a year and a half ago and
we've been friends ever since when does
David Tobruk upload his vlogs my
schedules Monday Wednesday Friday but
lately I've been uploading Tuesday
Thursday and Saturday cuz I get really
late oh my god two more of these this is
the home stretch I gotta kill these
where did david dobrik come from and can
we send him back originally Slovakia and
then Ohio and then Chicago and if you're
asking like what social media platform I
came from and vine where does david
dobrik get the white tables ikea i buy a
bunch of white tables to someone that
has no idea about anything about me this
question definitely don't make any sense
but IKEA where does david dobrik work
honestly anywhere where someone would
let me point a camera at them where did
david dobrik go to college i went to is
you know i apply to ISU and then i
decided not to go there and then I went
to Community College for half a semester
and on my last day at Community College
I got caught cheating and I never went
back again and now I'm here to one of
these I'm gonna take a long time in
these last couple because I really want
to enjoy this moment
why does david dobrik call Nick Jonas I
didn't know people know about this I
call him often I found his number and
I'm just been calling him ever since
why david dobrik doesn't drink alcohol
because he's scared he's scared of what
he will do when he is under the
influence of alcohol and he can't handle
his liquor after david dobrik i spawned
a beer beer door brooke has to go nap
nap why david dobrik might get deported
because i'm not a citizen and i don't
have a visa when i get deported there'll
be my vacation I'm probably gonna do
Canada maybe Toronto maybe Fiji I don't
know maybe I'll have a good time with
this deportation
why doesn't david dobrik have an accent
i think i tried really hard when i was a
kid to get rid of any signs of me being
from another kind
country but now now maybe an accident
would be cool this is the last one oh
why was David dobrik evicted a couple of
times they get we got to that situation
it's just a bunch of shenanigans around
the house my roommates have sex really
loud and I don't stop them so it's kind
of my fault - what trick can david
dobrik dude thanks for asking
I'm gonna show you I'll end this from
Selena Gomez she did this in an
interview once but I'm gonna one-up it
or I won't be able to get it here we go
[Music]
it'll be worth it once we get it right